Speaker 1: What may come as a shock to some, but
not others, is new testimony from Dr. Deborah
Burks. Remember Dr. Burke's prominent figure
early in the pandemic response under the Trump
administration, Dr. Deborah Burks now says the
Trump administration could have prevented 30 to
40 percent of COVID deaths had Trump taken
different actions and taken the pandemic
more seriously. Newsweek report Burks estimates
Trump administration could have prevented
could 30 to 40 percent of COVID deaths. The Trump
administration's former coronavirus adviser,
Dr. Deborah Burks, estimated that 30 to 40 percent
of the 700 38000 COVID 19 deaths in the U.S.
could have been prevented had the White House
taken necessary steps to curb the spread of
the virus. In a closed door testimony conducted
by the House Select Coronavirus Subcommittee on
October 12 and 13, Brooks tested. Divide that more
than 130000 American lives could have been saved
in the adminis if the administration
promoted mask wearing and social distancing
in the early days of the pandemic, according to
excerpts shared by the committee, Burke said.
I believe if we had fully implemented the
mask mandates, the reduction in indoor dining,
the getting friends and family to understand the
risk of gathering in private homes, and we had
increased testing that we probably could have
decreased fatalities into the 30 percent less
to 40 percent less range. Asked whether former
President Donald Trump did everything he could
have to handle the pandemic, Burke said no. And
I've said that to the White House in general,
and I believe I was very clear to the
president in specifics of what I needed
him to do. We suspected this, but we didn't
exactly know how to quantify it. We knew,
of course, we would have had deaths regardless.
All countries have had them, but we suspected the
numbers would have been lower had Trump taken this
seriously. When Trump was saying We have 15 cases,
which will soon be zero, I mean, at this point,
a globally humiliating statement to have made
if he had been doing something instead of
downplaying it, we knew the death count
would have been lower. We just didn't know how
much lower the U.S. Postal Service had a plan
to mail out masks to everybody, and it got shot
down, all in the name of slowing down the Postal
Service for the election and in not making it seem
as though this was really a problem. And then,
of course, you had the falsehoods and you had the
misinformation spread during 2020. Those to this
day are killing people, people who, because of the
disinformation, refused to wear masks, people who,
because of the disinformation, refused to get
themselves vaccinated. Another report on this
in a Business Insider Trump's White House ignored
advice on COVID that could have saved over 130000
lives, Brooks said. Brooks testified that the
2020 election distracted Trump from the pandemic.
So is it good that Dr. Burks is saying
this? Yeah, I guess it's good. Was she
a purveyor of disinformation during her time
as coronavirus adviser? Absolutely. And we
can go back and forth and say, Well, she was in a
really tough position, or she may have calculated,
I need to stay because if I leave, this gets
even worse. But remember that completely
bizarre interview where she said Donald Trump
is just amazing at paying attention to the facts
and making decisions on that basis on COVID?
And we looked at it and we said, What the hell
is he talking about here? What on earth is this?
This doesn't make any sense whatsoever. And yet
she continued to insist, No, no, no, he's doing
now, OK? Later, it was intimated, it was said,
it was suggested, you know, she was in a delicate
situation. There was only so much she could said.
But I mean, you guys remember this stuff, right?
Speaker 3: And then I see the disinfectant. Is
there a way we can do something like
that by injection inside opposing you
brought the light inside the body, right?
Speaker 1: You guys remember all that stuff.
And Dr. Burks, I mean, OK. She looked confused,
but she continued to run interference for that
administration until it was too late. So great.
She lets us know that we were right in what we
suspected. Trump not only could have prevented
30 to 40 percent of deaths, by the way he
could have easily sailed to reelection by
doing it. As I've said many times before,
COVID was a major drag on Trump's reelection,
which ultimately didn't happen, and he lost.
He lost badly in the popular vote to Joe Biden.
But it was only a few hundred thousand votes in
a few states that electorally handed Donald Trump
a defeat. If from day one, Trump had simply said,
We are going to, we are really going to take this
as seriously as anyone. Listen to these doctors,
wear your masks. We've got Trump masks. It's
so stupid. But if he had done that right away,
he would have sailed to reelection and we would
have saved many, many people. So Dr. Burke
certainly deserves criticism, as we've said
before. But there is no question that not
only could Trump have saved people, he could be
president right now if he had better handle that.
Let me know your thoughts. We're going to have
more coverage of this on The David Pakman Show
Instagram. Make sure you're following us there at
David Pakman show. You can follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman. We will get to the latest on
the January 6th Committee after this short break.